this is tamar hussein reading for
reviewer alessandro filari
watchdog's legion takes the foundations
and ideas of its predecessors and
expands upon them
exponentially the core conceit of legion
lies in the old adage of strength in
numbers
which manifests by letting you recruit
and play as nearly any character you
come across in the game
this open-ended stance to fighting the
system is a significant change for the
franchise and it's bolstered by improved
hacking and social engineering gameplay
legion's approach while admirable does
have some unintended issues that makes
its powerful message of unity waver in
opportune times
but it still manages to make a profound
statement about hope
legion is all about bringing
long-standing hacker group dedsec
out from the shadows and mobilizing the
citizens of london
against an authoritarian regime london
and its citizens are effectively caught
in a vice grip of encroaching fascism
due to the occupation of albion a
private military group along with
criminal and corporate enterprises
taking advantage of the power vacuum
the london and watchdogs legion is
presented as a more advanced and
exaggerated version of the real life
london however this interpretation of
the city still reflects the present mood
of 2020 albeit with a more cyberpunk
aesthetic
in a game with multiple characters the
one constant that you'll have across
them is your connection to london itself
the game manages to capture the history
and cultural diversity of london while
also juxtaposing it with the dark
presence of albion
who detains citizens in plain sight
[Music]
we could use that power for good the
main story of legion is heavy in its
subject matter
it grapples with themes around
nationalism capitalism classism
and of course policing although the
execution is somewhat scatter shot
the moments in which the game chooses to
shine a light on these pervading issues
can be sobering
the most notable example involves a
guest appearance by british gram rapper
stormzy
who gives a rousing and powerful
performance confronting systemic racism
through text messages podcasts and other
supplementary means of delivering
narrative
legion lays bare even more of the issues
plaguing society
text messages reveal that albion
effectively a police force is targeting
and harassing citizens in public
and recalling this information as you
watch people on the streets fall victim
to these practices can sting
radio shows mock the in-game right-wing
ideologies which
when described sound ridiculous and the
stuff of fiction
but aren't all that far from what we
hear in real life
the people claiming their medical
shortages are probably high on
lots of medicine that they've been
i for one believe that there are no
medical shortages andy just last week i
went in with a broken arm and they
suggested it might just be extreme
period pain and described me a drink of
water in an astrology chart
what really hits home about watchdog's
legion is that as the cartoonishly bleak
world comes into focus
it becomes difficult to ignore the
immediate parallels to our own real
world society
sure it might not interrogate the issues
and explore the nuances with a great
deal of depth
but the broad strokes of the brush are
enough to blur the line between fiction
and reality
and at that point you have to confront
just how far our own society has fallen
for the most part the main narrative
does a decent job of tackling these
topics but its focus is
scatter shot and the game's scope is too
broad to deliver its message in a sharp
concise way as a result the 25 hour main
plot can feel like it drifts into the
periphery as the core narrative becomes
secondary to the moment to moment
actions
and the events that occur when the open
world mechanics are at work
the knock-on effect is that side
activities are left to do
a lot of the heavy lifting on exploring
the nuance in these themes which they do
admirably despite some issues with tonal
inconsistency that come from the open
ended character selection this can lead
to some unexpected and bizarre shifts in
tone with some of the more colorful
characters sticking out uncomfortably
during more serious parts of the story
so this is what this country does to
people with wrong stamps on their
passports
cool so cool so glad that i live here
despite its dark story playing legion
can still often be a light-hearted
experience
and the game has plenty of side stories
that let you use your operatives and
over-the-top
hacking powers to bend the environment
to your whim once you begin to liberate
london and take on higher stakes
missions
you'll eventually unlock more skilled
and less subtle operatives such as spies
with access to cars outfitted with
cloaking and rockets
and drone engineers who can summon robot
bees to swarm enemies like previous
games
watchdog's legion hinges on the familiar
loop of open mode gameplay which entails
exploration
combat stealth and in-game narrative
events watchdog's legion reaches its
high when it's channeling elements of
immersive sims
where many of your choices can cascade
into a satisfying chain
of reactions that yield the desired
result hacking is your core connection
to the world
and it opens up many clever
opportunities when it comes to figuring
out how to achieve your present goals
and it's always satisfying coming up
with ways to bend the environment to
complete your tasks with minimal
resistance
coupled with the randomly generated
playable characters legion presents many
interesting opportunities to take
advantage of and its core gameplay
represents the prospect of the watchdogs
hacker fantasy at its best
it can be bizarre seeing what sort of
characters you pull in on your crusade
and it's solid fun getting used to
whatever skills they have
in some critical missions to succeed by
the skin of their teeth
while each operative is capable missions
can and will likely turn
sour after a wrong decision resulting in
all sorts of enemies coming down on you
with assault rifles and combat drones
the potential addition to this stress is
the option to enhance the campaign to
include permanent deaths for your
operatives meaning once they fall in a
mission
they're gone for good it's a clever
addition that adds a bit more realism
and a greater sense of consequence to
the campaign which can make some of the
more daring missions feel more
stressful especially knowing that losing
a favorite operative will leave a
lasting sting
legion leans heavily into randomly
generated content when recruiting new
operatives and seeing where their story
takes you
over time however it can be easy to fall
into a familiar and repetitive loop of
recycled objectives and dialogues set in
all too familiar areas
albeit with different voiceovers as
engaging as it is to constantly bounce
around characters
over time legion's many wacky excursions
around london can give rise to periods
of aimlessness
without a centralized viewpoint and
structure to guide you in moments like
this the overall narrative
and the tonal issues that watchdog's
legion has can
force their way to the front of the mind
but the core gameplay of hacking the
world
making connections and seeing your
favorite operative succeed is satisfying
enough that it makes it easier not to
get hung up on them
in the past ubisoft has had an
unfortunate history of missing the mark
when it comes to utilizing real world
events
politics and other hot button issues as
the backdrop for their games
however watchdog's legion does a lot to
confront topics like fascism inequality
and the idea that technology exposes and
amplifies old fears and hatreds
legion not only does an effective job of
showing the banality of evil in plain
sight but also
in a more optimistic light shows how the
citizens look to london's culture and to
each other to overcome oppression
watchdog's legion is an anti-fascist
game and it's admirable that it sticks
to this message and sees it through to a
satisfying and affirming conclusion
it also bolsters the franchise's clever
hacking gameplay to offer more
creativity than ever
one of legion's more profound messages
is about what it means to be a true
londoner and by the game's end you'll
have a deadset crew made out of wildly
diverse
and disparate citizens from unique
cultural ethnic
and economic backgrounds all united in
their goal to restore their home
if anything that's as powerful a message
for the game as you can get
think i'm getting this dead sex thing
you wouldn't have been recruited if
deadset thought you'd be killed that
easily
right you're running some cheeky beta
program bagley
don't let bagley get under your skin job
well done